Transcription:
Relecteur: eric vautier
Yes, merci beaucoup !
J’avoue, je n’ai pas toujours
eu cette tête-là.
Petit, j’étais plutôt gros,
j’avais les cheveux plats, tout lisses,
et on m’appelait Bouboule.
Mais ça, c’était il y a 30 ans, au moins.
D’ailleurs, savez-vous qu’en 2030,
65 % d’entre vous exerceront un métier
qui n’existe pas encore ?
Rien de grave, je vous rassure.
C’était pareil pour moi à mon époque.
On n’imaginait pas du tout l’impact
que l’informatique aurait
sur notre quotidien.
J’avais pourtant le sentiment que moi,
c’était ça, le futur.
Alors pendant que mes potes
allaient, eux, au tennis,
le mercredi, je prenais
des cours d’informatique.
Je sentais que je mettais en place
des connexions dans mon cerveau.
Mais comment optimiser le code
dans sa tête ?
Une première réponse m’est apparue
avec le Rubik's Cube.
Pour le résoudre, c’est plutôt simple.
Il suffit de prendre le temps
de l’observer.
Ensuite, seulement, les doigts
et les mains prennent le relais.
Puis on recommence, on observe.
Et les mains et les doigts
prennent le relais.
Et on recommence, on recommence,
en boucle.
Ces cycles reflètent assez bien
le type d’échanges qu’il y a entre
le cerveau gauche et le cerveau droit
dans notre cerveau.
Je me suis dit : « Je vais appréhender
tous les systèmes de cette manière-là. »
D’abord, dans un premier temps,
envisager, visualiser
la structure de base,
celle qui est inamovible,
qu’on ne peut pas remplacer,
qui soutient les couches superficielles.
Ensuite, justement, identifier
quelles sont les couches superficielles
qui complètent cette structure de base
et forment l’ensemble qui est perçu
par notre cerveau et nos cinq sens.
Cette modélisation visuelle est devenue
un système de pensée
qui me permet de naviguer maintenant.
Le deuxième déclic a eu lieu
quand je me suis mis à la guitare.
Oui, un jour, je me suis mis à la guitare.
Et sans le savoir, j’étais déjà
en train de faire une mise à jour
de mon système de pensée.
De programmeur-thinker à cubeur-thinker,
j’étais en train de passer
à un autre modèle.
Et c’est celui dont j’ai envie
de vous parler maintenant.
Le Music Thinking,
cette identité professionnelle,
est celle qui me permet maintenant
de naviguer confortablement
de business en business.
Et la chance fait qu’elle se consolide
encore plus à chaque étape.
Ça n’a pas coulé de source ; au début,
j’ai cru qu’il suffirait simplement
de reprendre les modèles élaborés
dans la programmation ou sur le cube
et de les coller sur la guitare.
Mais non ! Non, non, non, non.
Non, ça n’a pas marché. Pas du tout.
Ce n’est pas comme ça que ça se passe.
Il me manquait une dimension
que je n’arrivais pas à identifier.
Et ce n’était pas la technique pure
ni les algorithmes
qui allaient me transformer
en Jimi Hendrix.
Alors, j’ai juste monté un groupe
avec des potes, on a pris notre pied,
en imaginant qu’on allait bosser
dans la cybernétique.
Ça faisait genre à l’époque.
C’est un jour, quand une copine m’a dit :
« Mais tu rigoles ! T’es un super mec !
Tu joues de la guitare ! »
que j’ai saisi cette inconnue
à mon équation.
C’était la dimension affective.
Cette sensibilité aux émotions
me permettait alors de déployer
des interactions avec les autres humains.
En fait, ça voulait dire que moi,
ado qui jouais de la guitare,
je pouvais enfin plaire aux filles.
(Rit)
Grâce à l’écoute, j’arrivais
à comprendre ce qu'il se passait
et à envisager
d’autres types de relations.
Je décidais alors d’affiner
cette perception
et cette restitution des émotions.
Ça a porté ses fruits ;
j’en ai fait mon métier.
Et depuis plus de vingt ans,
c’est un de mes métiers
et une passion.
La musique est un médium
extraordinaire pour triturer les émotions
et les sentiments.
En studio, par exemple, j’ai appris
comment composer un tube
qui est capable de se démarquer
entre deux publicités
pour un lave-vaisselle et une voiture,
ou encore se démarquer
sur le dancefloor imbibé
entre deux mégatubes internationaux.
Sur scène aussi, j’ai beaucoup appris.
Le métier de musicien engendre
des collaborations qui sont tissées
dans des conditions
pas toujours très agréables,
qui varient sans cesse entre
la grande détente — on est tous potes,
on se fait la bise —
et la haute pression du « there’s no
business like show business ».
Imaginez la piscine d’un hôtel
cinq étoiles, la nuit, après, en fait,
un concert qui s’est très très
très très très très mal passé
devant une brochette de VIP
qu’il fallait convaincre.
Ça forge.
Ou encore,
onze heures de voyage,
complètement jet-lagged,
qui s’enchaînent avec un concert
devant vingt mille personnes
qui chantent et qui dansent
sur le son de vos doigts
qui, eux, sont encore engourdis.
Pour, juste après, partir à l’arrache,
juste après les dédicaces,
aller voir des baleines,
à l’autre bout du monde,
avec dans le ventre juste une poutine
pour vous tenir l’estomac.
Ça laisse des traces.
Travailler dans cet environnement
m’a permis quand même
de faire évoluer
ma visualisation des systèmes
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l’heure.
En fait, c’est comme une chanson.
Vous avez le texte qui se tient
sur la mélodie,
qui elle-même est soutenue
par une série d’accords
qui défile dans le temps.
Et ces derniers sont fondamentalement
posés sur des basses.
En bougeant, en triturant,
en distorsionnant
un de ces éléments dans le temps,
je génère de l’émotion.
Et cela appelle du sentiment.
C’est formidable !
C’est ainsi que ces dizaines
de milliers d’heures passées
à co-créer des chansons pop,
des arrangements,
des orchestrations sophistiquées,
des spectacles un peu glamour,
sont maintenant devenues
de la valeur dans les secteurs
de la finance, dans l’industrie du meuble
ou même, tout simplement,
en famille ou sur mon snowboard.
Le Music Thinking,
c’est ce que j’utilise aujourd’hui
dans un tiers de mon activité.
Ce tiers-là consiste à accompagner
des entreprises dans l’innovation.
C’est très à la mode en ce moment.
Ça ressemble à peu près à des workshops,
du travail en groupe avec des gens
qui n’ont pas d’idées.
On les accompagne dans la créativité
à l’aide d’outils visuels
pour essayer de trouver des solutions.
Ces outils visuels sont issus d’une
méthode qui s’appelle le Design Thinking
et dans ce contexte, j’y applique, donc,
ce que moi, j’appelle le Music Thinking.
Ça consiste tout simplement à appliquer
les usages et les réflexes
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l’heure
dans ces milieux un peu plus corporate
ou académiques.
L’exemple le plus simple, c’est comment
je peux coacher des gens
en leur parlant de tempo, de rythme,
de refrains accrocheurs,
d’incarnation du propos.
Plus bluffant, une histoire assez drôle,
c’est comment j’ai réussi un jour
à gérer une crise managériale.
Imaginez une manageuse en furie
qui a réussi à envoyer tous les mecs
du bureau à l’autre bout de la salle.
J’ai posé ma veste comme ça, je me suis
assis sur le bureau et je lui ai dit :
« Écoute, ma chérie.
Tes musiciens ne sont pas parfaits,
mais c’est les meilleurs du monde.
Ta chanson, tu la connais.
Alors, ne t’en fais pas,
on va y arriver. »
Devinez quoi, la diva s’est levée,
tranquille, l’air de rien,
elle a repris là où elle en était
et tout s’est bien passé.
Une autre fois encore, j’étais
sur un plateau avec Katy Perry
et je voulais des photos.
Je donne mon boitier
à un mec au bord de la scène
« Excuse-moi, tu peux me prendre
des photos pendant que je joue ? »
Le mec ne me répond pas, il me regarde
avec de grands yeux et je vois bien
qu'il n'a pas du tout envie
de me prendre en photo.
En fait, c’était l’artiste suivant,
un DJ de renom,
genre connu dans le monde entier,
mais que je ne connaissais pas.
Ça m’a servi. Depuis, avant chaque
réunion, je checke qui sont les gens
dans la salle et, surtout,
quel est leur statut,
qui n’est jamais écrit sur leur front.
En fait, ça a tout changé.
Depuis, j’arrive à parler à des présidents
du CAC 40 comme ça,
en one to one, en mode rock star.
Et c’est plutôt pratique.
J’en ai des dizaines,
des histoires comme ça.
Mais celle dont je vais vous parler
maintenant, c’est la première fois
que j’ai appliqué consciemment
ce mode de Music Thinking.
On m’avait demandé de faire
une présentation
pour les résultats financiers
d’une filiale d'un groupe.
Les chiffres étaient excellents
et la directrice voulait autre chose
qu’un pauvre Power Point,
vous voyez ce que je veux dire.
Donc, elle m’a appelé
et j’ai dégainé le V.
Cette courbe, elle est née, en fait,
en répétition, un jour.
J’étais avec un groupe de rock.
On savait jouer nos morceaux
dans tous les sens.
Alors, pour s’amuser, on réajustait
les titres dans ce qui nous amusait
et en fonction de l’auditoire,
en respectant quand même
sept principes d’énergie.
Au début, vous avez un crochet
qui sert à prendre l’auditeur par la main
et à le garder avec vous.
Ensuite, il fallait qu’on fasse
toujours attention
à trouver le morceau le plus mou,
le slow, la ballade -
tout le monde veut l'entendre
mais il plombe l’ambiance.
On s’arrangeait pour le mettre au creux
de la vague, là où tout le monde dort.
Et le plus important,
c’est au niveau de la boucle,
vous avez l’offrande, le cadeau.
C’est le morceau,
le titre le plus énergique.
Celui qui va faire danser tout le monde.
Au début, vous remplissez aussi avec,
au niveau de la bosse, un tube assuré,
histoire de vous mettre dans l’ambiance,
et, pour conclure, vous avez le rappel.
C’est le morceau qui va trotter dans
toutes les têtes et qui va donner
aux gens [l’envie] de revenir
vous voir la prochaine fois.
En business, c’est le « one more thing »
de Steve Jobs.
Et pour la présentation
des résultats financiers,
ça s’est passé comme ça.
Au début, on a affiché le titre accrocheur
de sa présentation.
Ensuite, au niveau de la bosse,
on a fait une annonce un peu sexy.
Dans ce genre de présentation,
c’est rempli de données, de data,
de trucs imbitables.
On les met juste derrière,
en direction du creux.
Il faut s’assurer de mettre les
plus mauvais chiffres tout en bas,
quand tout le monde dort.
Ensuite, pour remonter, vous mettez
une petite annonce, une bonne nouvelle,
et en haut, au niveau de la boucle,
quand tout le monde est réveillé,
vous parlez du produit phare,
celui qui a généré le plus de bénéfices
et que tout le monde connaît.
Pour conclure, c’est assez facile,
vous parlez d’un truc prometteur,
quelque chose qui va bien se passer
et vous avez déjà gagné,
tout est possible.
Cette courbe,
elle marche vraiment pour tout.
Je m’en sers, je pense, pratiquement
deux ou trois fois par semaine
depuis plus de vingt ans.
C’est assez extraordinaire.
Je m’en sers pour faire des
présentations, donc, écrire des livres,
créer des jeux vidéo ;
je fais tout ça, oui.
Oh, plein d’autres choses encore.
Et notamment, je m’en suis servi
pour… une idée ?
Je n’ai pas bien entendu…
Je m’en suis servi pour ce TEDx !
Regardez, au début, je vous ai accrochés
avec le « J’avoue » et Bouboule.
Ensuite, je vous ai parlé de vos futurs
emplois, à réinventer.
Puis, j’ai enchaîné avec les exemples,
les exemples, les exemples
[dont il] il fallait parler.
Et maintenant, nous sommes en bas,
vous dormez ?
Dans le V ?
Et maintenant, je vais vous parler
de l’état de flow.
L’état de flow, quelqu’un le connaît ?
C’est cet état mental que tu atteins
quand tu es extrêmement concentré,
sans faire d’effort,
tu es à fond dans l’engagement
et plus rien autour ne compte.
Apparemment, ça correspond à
des cycles fluides entre le cerveau gauche
et le cerveau droit qui se situent entre
7,5 Hz et 12,5 Hz, qu’on appelle aussi
« ondes alpha ».
Cet état mental est tellement agréable
que le temps ne compte plus,
non seulement le temps,
mais plus rien autour ne compte.
Mais d’ailleurs, pourquoi vous parlé-je
du flow maintenant ?
Parce que justement, c’est lui,
le dénominateur commun.
Le commun entre toutes les expériences
dont je vous ai parlé,
qui sont toutes variées.
Cet état mental qui est hors du temps,
c’est lui qui me permet à chaque fois
de valider, par exemple, qu’une session
de travail collaborative
est bien comprise, qu’un rendez-vous
d’affaires est sur la bonne voie,
qu’un cours de guitare est assimilé.
Mais le meilleur exemple pour vous
expliquer le flow, c’est de vous expliquer
comment on en sort.
Vous regardez un film
et le mot « fin » apparaît à l’écran.
Sauriez-vous me dire, juste avant
le mot « fin », étiez-vous dans le film
ou dans la vraie vie ?
C’est pareil, à la fin d’un bon livre,
quand le mot « fin » apparaît,
étiez-vous dans le livre
ou dans la vraie vie ?
À la fin d’une bonne partie
d’un jeu vidéo, étiez-vous
dans le jeu ou dans la vraie vie ?
C’est pareil, en bas de la piste de ski,
juste avant, où sommes-nous ?
Serions-nous dans un état de flow ?
En groupe, en plus ?
En fait, nous sommes là, au niveau
de la boucle.
Et c’est le moment, pour conclure,
que je vous parle des métiers
qu’il reste à inventer.
Parce que, justement,
demain, vous allez avoir
plusieurs métiers, c’est certain.
Alors je vous invite dès aujourd’hui
à multiplier les opportunités,
à essayer beaucoup de choses.
Essayez, hackez, modifiez les usages
pour vous forger et trouver
une identité professionnelle.
Cela vous permettra de louvoyer
d’un business à l’autre,
un peu comme je le fais maintenant.
Cela vous permettra aussi
de partager de la connaissance
avec d’autres cerveaux,
d’autres types de cerveaux,
des humains, d’autres humains,
ou pas, d’ailleurs,
des robots, peut-être, certainement,
voire des humanoïdes.
Pour ça, essayez, inventez, hackez
des usages, ayez des recettes,
améliorez la pensée qui vous ressemble.
Devenez votre propre avatar professionnel.
En un mot, créez le hashtag
qui vous ressemble.
Créez le hashtag de votre état d’esprit.
Le mien, c’est Music Thinking.
Quel est le vôtre ?
Quel est votre hashtag ?
À vos hashtags, donc !
À vos dièses, dirais-je.
Merci !
(Applaudissements)